hey guys it's Pete I was working on part
two of my Queen Cersei series today in
this prophecy about Maggy the Frog came
up again I mentioned a couple times in
my other videos already so I decided to
make a separate video to break it down
there will be lots of spoilers and
speculation here so if you aren't caught
up in the show or in the books you'll
probably want to stop watching right now
three questions you get your are my
nails I've been promised to the prince
when will we marry you'll never wake the
Prince you know what the King but I will
be queen oh yes you'll be queen for a
time it comes another younger more
beautiful to cast you down and take all
you all dear
well the King and I have children no the
king will have 20 children and you'll
have three that doesn't make sense
gold will be their crowns God the
shrouds
if you remember the scene that I just
showed at the beginning from that was at
the beginning of season 5 episode 1 and
it was a strange in someone ominous
beginning to to the season it's a
flashback from Searcy's childhood and
she's thinking about it on the way to
her father's funeral
this fortune-teller is called Maggie the
frog in the books and even though the
show takes what she what she says
directly from the source material it
leaves a few important bits out magic
and prophecy or a gray area in the world
of A Song of Ice and Fire because we
know some magic exists in this alternate
reality but at the same time prophecy by
nature is vague and open to
interpretation this particular prophecy
is recurring in the books something that
is always in the back of Circe's mind
since they decided to make it an opening
scene of a season you would think that
it is important part of a show Cersei
story so let's break it down and let's
think about what Maggie said and
discussed what was left out Cersei says
I've been promised to the prince when
will he marry Maggie responds you'll
never Wed the Prince you'll Wed the king
the context context in the books is at
this encounter happens during attorney
that's held in Lannisport to celebrate
King Aerys the second visiting the
westerland's young Cersei first sees
Rhaegar Targaryen there the Crown Prince
and heir to the Iron Throne and she like
immediately becomes enamored with him
she says she's been promised to the
prince which is a little bit confusing
Lord Tywin's plan was always to marry
Cersei to Rhaegar but Aerys never agreed
to it so technically in the books at
least she was never promised to any
Prince she did believe it though from
like from what her father told her and
she is definitely talking about Rhaegar
when she asked the question Maggie says
turns out to be true though when Robert
Baratheon takes the throne as king she
ends up marrying him after the Targaryen
have been removed for power it's
important to note though that she at the
time misinterpreted what the meaning of
it was she thought it meant that she'd
end up marrying Rhaegar just after her
father died so you know it was true but
Cersei didn't have the right understand
of it circe then says but I will be
queen Maggie says oh yes you'll be queen
for a time then comes another younger
more beautiful to cast you down and take
all you hold dear so the Queen part
obviously came true when Cersei married
Robert the second part isn't clear but
it plays a big role in Sarah's paranoia
related to the Tyrells and her
decision-making once Tom and takes the
throne in the books we'll talk about
that more in a minute Cersei then says
well the King and I have children Maggie
responds the king will have 20 children
you will have three Cersei says that
doesn't make sense and Maggie says gold
will be their crowns gold their shrouds
so here Maggie gets it right again she
counts the number of Robert's bastards
which are in the show where it says 20
but in the books it was 16 but either
way she gets it right and she counts the
three children's thirst he had with
Jamie which were passed off as Robert
remember Robert got Cersei pregnant once
but she never had the child and to make
sure this didn't happen again she would
take moon tea whenever they had been
together this doesn't make sense to
young Cersei but it turns out to be
exactly what happens go gold will be
their crowns it's most likely a
reference to Joffrey Marcella and Tom's
hair since this has turns out to be a
clue to who they're you know to their
real parentage that Jon Arryn stumbles
on later on in the story you can make an
argument to Joffrey and Tommen end up
wearing actual gold crowns but Marcella
isn't alive in the show anymore so she
definitely never will if you're
wondering what shout trials are they're
most likely just the cloth that you know
her children's bodies are wrapped in
after their death my thinking on this is
that it's you know a golden funeral
shroud would be one that's related to
someone who died young you know golden
child kind of thing but there are other
interpretations as well either way this
seems to point that to the fact that all
of Circe's children will die before she
does and that turns out to be true at
this point in the show we see a look of
shock on Circe's face and as a drop of
blood from her thumb hits the ground we
cut back to her arriving at the great
Sept in King's Landing as an adult for
book readers this is a strange twist
because the last thing Maggie tells
Cersei is omitted and the books that
continues with the old woman was not
with her however gold shall be their
crowns and gold their shrouds she said
and when your tears have drowned you the
Ballon car will shot shall wrap his
hands about your pale white throat and
choke the life from you
this is like a really important part of
the prophecy to leave out valonqar is a
high balerion word that translates to
little brother the Maggie is saying that
after all her children die Circe's
younger brother will choke her to death
so and like why would the show leave
this out it's possible that the first
flashback would be followed up with
another one later on in a way that
actually makes sense because if you
break the prophecy up they aren't
delivering they're like they can avoid
like delving too deeply into Circe's
murder motivations for making decisions
since the book is written in
point-of-view chapters we get a bunch
better idea of what each character is
thinking if we learned that Cersei was
likely to be killed by one of one of her
brothers it may have undermined the
overall arc of the relationship on the
show and the show Maggie is batting a
hundred percent as none of what she's
told Cersei so far has been proven
incorrect in the books we also have a
little more information that reinforces
the accuracy because the girl who is
with Cersei molera
asked Maggie one of her questions before
they leave she asks if she will marry
Jaime to which Mark Maggy the Frog
answers not Jaime nor any other man
worms will have your Maidenhead your
death is here tonight little one can you
smell her breath she is very close that
Knight molera falls into a well and dies
and when Cersei tells the story you get
the idea that she probably was the one
who pushed her in either way Maggie got
it right and at this point it gets hard
to discount her ability to see the
future although Cersei has made maggy's
prophecy in the back of her mind and
revisits the memory often in the books
we don't have much else to test her
accuracy in one conversation with Qyburn
Cersei brings it up and Chiron gives
credence to the power of blood magic she
as soon as the prophecy can be first
stalled and he says that it definitely
can when she asks how he says that he
thinks that she probably already knows
how this would imply that in order to
stop the prophecy she would have to kill
the younger more beautiful Queen the
problem with this is that Cersei
believes that this must be Margaery but
has no way to know for sure
she's already misinterpreted the first
part of the prophecy but
garlis sets out with the plan to kill
Tommen's new bride this is the problem
with prophecy in general since it is
usually vague and since everything
Maggie said so far has come true but you
know it all it really does is lead to a
huge amount of paranoia and Cersei where
the Margaery is the younger queen come
to take everything Cersei holds dear is
up for debate she did take Circe's boys
from her in marriage she married them
both and both of them were infatuated
with her
Margaery through her family's actions
literally took Joffrey from her by
killing him but Cersei never really
seems to suspect them as you know the
killers plus there is Marcella who gets
sent off to Dorne and that isn't really
related to anything about the rest of
the the kids or the Tyrells for that
matter for the way things are playing
out especially in the show I would argue
that what Cersei really holds dear is
her power she was always claimed that
her children were the most important
thing to her but protecting them has
always been tied to her protecting her
place as well it's not to say that she
never cared for her children because she
surely did but at this point they're all
gone and really all she has left is the
power that she's taken at the end of
season six she literally destroyed all
of her enemies in King's Landing to
avoid being found guilty at trial and
once Talman dies she just takes the
throne by force this would indicate that
Daenerys will be the more likely younger
more beautiful Queen who is definitely
on her way to try and take over the
throne as far as the Balon Corps is
concerned Cersei has always been certain
that this was Tyrion if you've ever
thought that the show goes a little
overboard in her hatred for Tyrion over
something that isn't his fault the death
of her mother in childbirth this is the
reason why she wants to get rid of him
because she is almost certain that he
will be her killer prior to season 7
tearing happens to be on his way back to
rest
Westeros so it may turn out that way and
he happens to be coming there with
Daenerys who is a younger more beautiful
Queen at least at this point but the
fact that she has misinterpreted and
misinterpreted things thus far is a
pretty good clue that Jaime is more
likely the Balon core of course it could
go either way but story wise it would be
a lot harder for Jaime to actually do it
like to actually kill her and that would
make for a much more
memorable scene and regardless of
everything else I mean that the show at
least is that's sort of what it's built
off of is those memorable scenes so in
conclusion it seems like Maggie the frog
has supernatural abilities much in the
same way Mary mazdoor did you know she
was de Maisie from daenerys storyline
you know the woman who uses blood magic
to bring back Drogo
Maggie tastes Circe's blood and answers
her questions about the future we can
point out events that prove each of her
prophecies turned out to be true and if
the show decides to include the rest of
the prophecy this means we should expect
one of her brothers to kill her before
the end of the series so what do you
guys think
I mean I'm generally a cynic when it
comes to most things related to prophecy
in their vague nature but it's kind of
hard to ignore that george RR martin you
know had maggie correctly predict the
number of children both Robert and
Cersei would have well in advance other
parts of the prophecy could be easily
explained away as being self-fulfilling
you know like she'd made decisions based
off the prophecy that led to the
problems but the number of children
would have you know that would have had
have been like a super amazingly good
guess in order for her to get that right
do you think Maggie could predict
Circe's future do you think that the
show will bring the balan core into the
mix do you think you know do we see
another flashback and if so you know who
do you think will be the Balon core do
you think it'll be Tyrion or do you
think it'll be Jaime please like the
video and don't forget to subscribe to
my channel I'm finishing up part two of
the Queen Cersei series after this and
I'm still working on my tourney at
Harrenhal series which will be out over
the next week I'm interested to see what
you guys think about the Maggy the Frog
and any other things that you are
thinking about based on prophecy you
know feel free to add those in the
comments and I'll talk to you soon